- Rach, we've been dating for over a year now, and I think it's about time people met my beautiful girlfriend.
What about us taking an adventure East?
- Like, Queens?
- Singapore. Colin's Wedding.
Don't you wanna meet my family?
- I hardly know anything about them.
Every time I bring them up, Nick changes the subject!
- Maybe his parents are poor,
and he has to send them money.
- We'll take your bags and
get you checked into first class.
- Nick, we can't afford this.
So your family's... rich?
- We're comfortable.
- That is exactly what a super rich person would say.
- 1.2 million.
- The Nick you're dating is Nick Young.
- Yeah, you guys know them or something?
- Hell yeah!
They're just the biggest developers in all of Singapore!
- Damn, Rachel. It's like the Asian bachelor.
- These people aren't just rich, they're crazy rich.
- Hey, you really should've told me that you're like, the Prince William of Asia.
- That's ridiculous.
I'm much more of a Harry.
- Mum, this is Rachel Chu.
- She just thinks you're some like, unrefined banana.
- No, no, no! That- those are for your fingers.
- Yellow on the outside, white on the inside.
- I chose to raise a family. For me, it was a privilege.
But for you, you may think it's old fashioned.
- Don't you want Nick to be happy?
- I know you're not what Nick needs.
- She's like, trying to play a game of chicken with me.
Thinking I'm gonna swerve like a chicken!
- But you can't swerve!
You gon' roll up and be like...
- Bawk bawk, bitch.
- Okay, maybe like, not as aggressive.
- I met a girl, I fell in love, and I wanna marry her.
- You're Nicholas Young, you're untouchable.
But Rachel's not.
- Have you prepped Rachel to face the wolves?
- I really admire you. It takes guts coming all the way over here facing Nick's family.
- I know this much:
You will never be enough.
- You know, it's about time someone
stood up to Auntie Eleanor.
Well you, not me. Oh God.
She can't know I was ever here.
- Ever since I can remember, my family has been my whole life.
Rachel. Rachel!
- If Nick chose me, he would lose his family. And if he chose his family...
he might spend the rest of his life resenting you.
- You nasty! You kinda nasty, you got nastier!